saludos para todos desde cabo cañaveral
como pueden ver con esta vista y a tan
sólo 24 kilómetros estoy en este momento
de donde se ha producido el despegue el
lanzamiento de ese cohete hace unos
minutos como pueden ver el cielos
parcialmente nublados y es que se
seguían muy de cerca las condiciones del
tiempo era de hecho la clave para
decidir si sería de nuevo pospuesto o no
este lanzamiento porque como saben ya
fue pospuesto una vez y de hecho había
una fecha tentativa para el lunes he
podido hablar con expertos cercanos a
este proyecto y me han contado que los
cuatro astronautas tres hombres y una
mujer han estado entrenando solo para
este proyecto durante los últimos tres
años han sido cientos de horas también
ellos vienen con cientos de horas de
experiencia en vuelo en tripulación y
han estado en el espacio previamente les
cuento la tripulación formada como les
decía por tres hombres y una mujer
tienen mucha experiencia por ejemplo un
dato muy curioso que he recabado es que
el astronauta megan mcarthur se sentó en
el día de hoy
imagino que emocionada porque se sentó
en el mismo asiento
su esposo también astronauta viajó a la
estación internacional la estación
espacial internacional hace ahora un año
y en materia de meteorología como les
decía a los analistas expertos y
meteorólogos de la nasa de la agencia
espacial han estado monitoreando las
condiciones del tiempo en las últimas
horas y entonces también he encontrado
recabado información sobre estos
chequeos y es que hay tres chequeos
críticos el último se sucede tan sólo a
una hora del despegue y el pse en el que
dicen ok o cancelamos ha sido ok hemos
recibido ese aquella minutos de
lanzamiento y desde aquí estamos
reportando ahora aclara este sería el
tercer lanzamiento de astronautas desde
suelo estadounidense tras la alianza de
la nasa con space ex le pregunto qué se
espera de estos cuatro astronautas que
realicen en la estación espacial
internacional
bueno precisamente en rueda de prensa el
astronauta francés toma pesqué que es
ingeniero aeroespacial aeronáutico
también piloto comentó que esta vez
tendrán tareas divididas los cuatro van
a ser parte del proyecto y van a dividir
las tareas eso sí vamos a destacar algo
y es que es que va a ser el supervisor
de esta misión en la segunda mitad del
proyecto y un dato curioso ellos cuatro
van a tardar 10 horas en llegar hasta la
estación internacional y ahí van a
encontrarse con el crew 1
este es el crew 2 el que está viajando
en estos momentos se van a encontrar con
tribuno y van a convivir 11 astronautas
en esa estación
pese a que ojo el número máximo fueron
fue de 13 astronautas el año pasado allí
van a estar explorando analizando
materiales que los científicos no tienen
acceso desde aquí desde la tierra y así
podrán darnos más información también
van a estar renovando y actualizando
cables nos contaban en una rueda de
prensa que tienen más de 20 años de
antigüedad clara gracias por toda esa
información de este lanzamiento
espectacular